هنا تبدو المسافات قصيره بين انقره ودمشق
بعد اكثر من عقد على القطيع لكنها لا تبدو
قريبه في وجهات النظر وان جمعتهما طويله
واحده وسقف واحد ففي اول اجتماع على مستوى
وزراء الخارجيه بين الجانبين تقترح روسيا
رسم خريطه الطريق لتطبيع العلاقات بينهما
قد تكون افضل نتيجه لتواصلنا هي الاتفاق
على توجيه الخبراء لاعداد مسوده خارطه
طريق للتطبيع بين سوريا وتركيا للاجتماع
الوزاري المقبل والتي سيتم ابلاغ رؤساء
دولنا بها
خريطه الطريق وفقا لموسكو تتضمن الالتزام
الثابت بالسياده جميع الدول المشاركه في
الاجتماع وسلامتها الاقليميه واستقلالها
ووحدتها والالتزام باهداف ومبادئ ميثاق
الامم المتحده واستعاده سريعه لعلاقات حسن
الجوار بين سوريا وتركيا على اسس المساواه
والمنفعه المتبادله اضافه الى ان الخريطه
ستسمح لدمشق وانقره بتحديد مواقفهما بوضوح
بشان القضايا ذات الاولويه بالنسبه لهما
الخريطه الروسيه تحدثت عن الخطوط العامه
لكنها لم تتطرق لنقاط الخلاف الجوهري بين
الجانبين التي يشكل انسحاب القوات التركيه
اهمها بنسبه لنظام السوري وبدونها سيبقى
الوضع يراوح مكانه كما يقول وزير الخارجيه
السوري بالمقابل تصر تركيا على قضيه
مكافحه الارهاب فهي ترى في وجود قوات
سوريا الديمقراطيه مبررا لبقائها العسكري
في سوريا وتامين حدودها وبين انقره ودمشق
يبدو الطريق باتجاه التطبيع مشوبا بخلافات
عميقه بحاجه لتنازلات لا يبدو الطرفان
مستعدين لتقديمها في الوقت الراهن
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات